so it's a four-hour actual movie i feel
like it's more of an assembly i think
you're right it's more of an assembly an
assembling of like madness we're delving
into every deleted scene taika ytt left
us wondering about in thor love and
thunder from brutal gore the god butcher
scenes to hilarious abba dance sequences
and jane foster's transformation into
mighty thor you may be wondering if you
truly saw the movie at all i heard that
this film had a few deleted scenes was
there anything that you were really sad
to see go so much
so much number one major post-credit
spoiler alert jane foster has quite the
character arc in this action-packed film
only taika ytt can have us laughing
through an entire movie only to bring us
to tears at jane's tragic yet beautiful
demise though she may technically be out
for the count the final post-credit
scene gives us a bit of hope that this
might not be the end of mighty thor jane
arrives in valhalla this is of course
the norse afterlife that's been
mentioned throughout these films but
never shown until now if you somehow
missed this definitely go back and check
it out she's greeted by heimdall both
are rogued and healthy looking and the
terrain of valhalla is depicted as
something like new asgard this ending
definitely opens up a can of
possibilities for the re-emergence of
some beloved mcu characters who do you
think could come back number two this
butchering did not make the final cut
everyone knows taika ytt loves to push
the limit when it comes to directing but
this is one scene that everyone agreed
might have been a bit too graphic for a
family-friendly film there's a prominent
moment where gore who is covered in
tattoos expressing his religious
devotion uses the necro sword to remove
them christian bale in an interview with
ign explains how although there was a
lot of great content in the shot
everyone found it to be a bit too
extreme
there was a lot of wonderful stuff that
we shot but you're going to experiment
some things can work some things don't
and we want this to be a family film
number three that feeling when your
entire universe gets deleted natalie
portman described it as joy and the the
sorrow of a taika or td project she
sadly explains how there's full planets
that are not there anymore what she's
referring to are all the guardians of
the galaxy scenes that were cut from the
film like there's a scene of thor
walking away from one of their battles
in the trailers like he's given up on
war there's also a moment where thor is
jokingly talking to the guardians about
taking a relaxing vacation this
definitely screams taika ytt improv
number four did you know tessa thompson
is actually obsessed with goats you have
a mild obsession with goats i wouldn't
characterize it as mild i think it's a
little more severe than that so it makes
sense that tessa would film an entire
scene just talking to the wild screaming
goats in thor love and thunder
number five the real thor fans know
exactly what we're talking about here
there were quite a few scenes in the
film that were taken straight from the
panels of the comics particularly
regarding gore's origin story comic book
panels taken out of the gore storyline
meant to show all the brutal takedowns
that gore has killing all these
different gods before he fights thor
this also brings us right into our next
deleted sequence number six or rather
lack thereof fans of the mcu are
definitely used to crossovers left and
right between tv shows and movies you
would think thor love and thunder would
be no different unfortunately due to the
timing of the two projects they couldn't
successfully cross storylines without
knowing which one would be released
first at the end of the day they just
decided it wasn't worth all the effort
christian bale gives us a great
explanation while speaking with the
direct we had versions of the story that
sort of teased gore's arrival and ones
that were sort of taking place in the
aftermath of that movie ultimately at
some point marvel just made the creative
decision you know what we don't
necessarily need this number 7. say what
now russell crowe has a brilliant cameo
as zeus in thor love and thunder but
apparently that wasn't always supposed
to be the character he portrayed a
marvel concept artist revealed he was
commissioned to create a comedic look
for crow as satan that concept artist
goes by the name of miles thieves and he
shares his experience doing the concept
art on his instagram page i was told by
the good folks at odd studio down in
australia who commissioned this art that
russell crowe might be having a good
comedic cameo as satan in the new thor
love and thunder it didn't work out that
way hopefully it wasn't because he saw
my drawings
number eight also known as natalie
portman's intense workout routine this
is definitely a scene that a lot of fans
would argue should not have been cut
from the film looking at you tyka
released footage from the asgard set
shows natalie portman filming what looks
like jane's transformation sequence in
the film we do see jane visiting that
spot but we don't actually get to see
her transformation take place
number nine yup you read that right thor
breaks it down for us to abba's song
waterloo this is definitely one of those
scenes we have to see again looking at
you tyka chris hemsworth is no stranger
to a dance sequence he shows us his
moves as billy lee in bad times at the
el royale and in the netflix film
spider-head it makes sense that would
eventually cross over to thor
it's a full
dance-off shooting lightning at his
fingertips and so on we don't know about
you guys but we absolutely have to see
this scene as soon as possible number
10. cue up the improv apparently there's
a very funny over-the-top scene where
thor comes in weeping about cork's death
that was an example of like us going
this is this is so funny and then
watching it
later
we don't know watching a teary-eyed thor
try to piece korg's body back together
with glue sounds like a great use of our
time number 11. we'll never say no to a
dance sequence we've already talked
about chris hemsworth's unseen abba
dance but did you know gore was also
supposed to have his own dancing scene
in true antagonist fashion gore was
supposed to start dancing right when he
thought he was going to win the fight
against thor the inspiration behind this
sequence came from aphex twins window
licker by the sounds of it it was going
to be too scary or dark as well because
in another interview bill also said
there was a lot more creepy as hell's
stuff number 12 this might be a bit of a
tearjerker christian bale talks about
how he got to work with quite a few
actors who we didn't get a chance to see
on screen i got to work with peter
dinklage the last time we got to see
peter dinklage who plays itree was in
avengers infinity war when thor came to
him in search of stormbreaker so
naturally it makes sense that gore would
visit etri for the same reason but the
sad part is itri most likely refused and
we're assuming gore doesn't take
rejection very well this would have been
quite a sad moment as itri was the last
of his kind with thanos already having
massacred the rest of his people number
13 wedding bells anyone apparently there
was an entire sequence where valkyrie
was supposed to find herself a queen to
join her on the throne whether
valkyrie's queen was in the original
script or it was just thompson's
thoughts about her character at the time
though isn't quite clear at the moment
regardless there is a theory about who
her potential queen could be something
you may not know is there could have
been a brand new character introduced to
thor love and thunder played by the
incredibly talented lena heady fans
theorized that she could have played
valkyrie's potential queen unfortunately
we may never know this to be true
because during an interview with insider
taika ytt breaks down his thought
process on why certain scenes were
dropped from the film i don't want
people to see the deleted scenes because
they're deleted for a reason they aren't
good enough the scenes were not in the
movie and that's it
so this wasn't the four-hour cut we
still truly want to see again looking at
you taika but we definitely got to
uncover a lot of mcu secrets with this
one what scenes do you wish were kept in
the film let us know in the comments and
thanks for hanging out with us here at
the things